Andrew Tay has just been arrested in  Romania the charge organized crime and  human trafficking him and his brother  had apparently been other investigations  since April but authorities were waiting  for proof that he was still in the  country before making their move and  when Andrew got in the fight with Greta  dunberg on Twitter police saw their  opening  during the argument Tate posted a video  of himself sending what a pizza box from  a local Romanian Pizza chain and by the  next day Andrew and Tristan were in  handcuffs however there is much more to  the story than meets the eye so  subscribe for part 2 because